this is going to be a very good year
very good
jan is at home jim is back
my protege ryan is a corporate
good stuff
um andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
blessed
[Music]
actually
it's kind of too bad we're not coming
into work tomorrow why i bet michael had
some elaborate theme party planned like
scrambled eggs saturday
i'm like hey everyone let's get your
boss laid saturday
i have an announcement
uh to make
i
am moving to costa rica
thought about it
for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so
i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
hey hey how's it going good especially
after i took all your money in poker
yeah
uh
hey uh can i talk about something about
when you want to give me more of your
money did you want to do that now we can
go inside i'm feeling kind of good
tonight
i was just um
i'm in love with you
what
i'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but i need you to
hear it
probably not good timing i know that i
just
what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
i just need you to know
once
well
i um
i
i can't
no
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be
come on
i don't want to do that
i want to be more than that
i can't
i'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not your fault
i'm sorry misinterpreted our friendship
you're right yes i get it i get it
michael okay here's what i'm gonna do
okay
we will move some money around
and i will personally see to it that you
have your party
you have your figs
i will be in attendance it's gonna be
great
how's that
i quit
what
michael you have no idea how high i can
fly
oh it's white we're so close
just buy us a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so i'll call you right back
okay great
hey dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
oh dwight we're so close
just buy us a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so i'll call you right back
okay okay great
so
hey dwight uh
sending the subs
oh
polly flax
marrying me will you be
your wife be coming
evil eyes
[Applause]
thank you
so guys guys guys guys
we're moving to colorado
all of us yep
wait what
holly has to go back to colorado i'm
going with her i'm leaving
hey jim jim
come here
do you know who that is
no look at him look at him t-shirt jeans
is it you
i am flattered
that's johnny depp where'd you take that
in my condo complex
oh my god that's right i read in people
magazine that he was looking for a
two-bedroom condo in scranton i'm
flipping out man well you remember my
idea for the fourth pirates sure that
they should do one hey
jim jim where where do i find the black
pearl who's that
captain jack sparrow captain jack
spierro jim john dillinger
no i'm captain jack sparrow captain
crunch
crunchy okay okay screw you
halpert you know it's not easy getting
excited about stuff
remember how you felt when you thought
you'd seen roger clemens at the yankees
game yeah well it wasn't him i had a
little bit of reason to believe that
you're right you're right
well you're not right because johnny
does i know your condo complex i know
it also explains why the name on his
mailbox was m shulman
i'm night shellman
but you know what it's okay
i'm totally fine
everything is gonna be totally fine
sorry
um are you ready for dinner tonight
yes
all right
then it's a date
i'm sorry what was the question
you